digamos que tenemos un objeto viajando
en forma circular y lo que dibuje aquí
son los vectores velocidad en diferentes
puntos de esta trayectoria tengo aquí mi
vector
v 1
aquí tengo mi vector
velocidad 2 y aquí tengo mi vector
velocidad 3
y vamos a asumir que aunque la posición
de sus vectores es diferente la magnitud
de estos vectores es la misma y es
constante voy a llamar a la magnitud de
los vectores b van a darse cuenta que
esto es una cantidad de escalar porque
no tiene la flechita arriba esto es una
cantidad escalar no es un vector y esta
vez minúscula la voy a llamar rapidez
y esta rapidez va a ser igual a la
magnitud
de los vectores
de uno
y esto va a ser igual a la magnitud del
vector
de 2
y esto a su vez será igual a la magnitud
del vector de 3
y vamos a asumir que este objeto está
viajando en una ruta circular
más o menos circular o imagínense que lo
que estoy dibujando es un círculo
con centro aquí y con un radio r ahora
lo que voy a hacer es dibujar los
vectores posición de cada uno de estos
puntos en el tiempo entonces tengo
y aquí acá
mi vector posición que voy a llamar
r 1
mi vector
posición acá
qué es
r2
y mi vector
posición
r 3
bueno entonces tenemos que la posición
va a ser diferente pero la magnitud de
estos vectores posiciones va a ser la
misma voy a llamar r
a la magnitud de cada uno de estos
vectores de nuevo este ere es un escalar
no es un vector no tiene una flechita
aquí y está r es igual a la magnitud
de mi vector de posición r 1 y esto es
igual
el vector a la magnitud de mi vector r 2
y es igual a la magnitud del vector r 3
lo que quiero hacer aquí es demostrarles
visualmente que dados este radio y esta
rapidez la magnitud de la aceleración
centrípeta que llamaré hace
aceleración centrípeta va a ser igual a
esta velocidad o esta persona esta
rapidez al cuadrado entre
el radio de rector posición
/ efe
vamos a llegar a esto pero ahorita vamos
a explicar visualmente de dónde sale
esta fórmula bueno aquí tengo entonces
mis vectores velocidad voy a tomar cada
uno de estos vectores y lo voy a
graficar de manera diferente tengo aquí
mi vector 1
este es
aproximadamente mi vector 2
y este
mi vector m3
cuál es el radio de este círculo qué
bueno si yo dibujara todo uno cada uno
de los vectores velocidad de mi objeto
pues tendríamos más o menos un círculo
también
cuál sería el radio de este círculo pues
sería la magnitud de mi vector velocidad
que es como les comenté una velocidad
constante entonces yo conozco que esta
magnitud de mi vector velocidad pues es
esto que ya me esté escalar el radio
la rapidez ve
y conocemos cuál es esta magnitud
y bueno sabemos que el radio de este
otro círculo pues es la magnitud del
vector posición y qué es lo que ocasiona
el cambio de dirección en estos vectores
velocidad bueno va a ser el vector
aceleración que si lo graficó va a ser
aquí así aceleración 1
este va así más o menos
rector aceleración 2 y este
vector aceleración 3
y quiero que ustedes noten la analogía
que hay aquí
conforme el objeto da vueltas el vector
posición va a ir cambiando como las
manecillas del reloj y aquí fuera se
muestran los vectores velocidad en este
otro ejemplo tenemos aquí adentro los
vectores velocidad que se muestran como
las manecillas de un reloj que van
cambiando y aquí lo que está causando el
movimiento son los vectores de
aceleración
en este otro lado de los vectores
velocidad son tangenciales a la posición
y son perpendiculares al radio lo mismo
va a ocurrir en esta parte donde la
aceleración es perpendicular a los
vectores velocidad si trasladamos todos
estos vectores aceleración aquí en este
círculo los dibujamos estos van a ser
los vectores aceleración
pues vamos a ver que todos van a estar
buscando el centro de estar van a estar
dirigiendo hacia el centro por lo que
todos estos son vectores de aceleración
centrípeta y asumimos que todos esos
vectores también tienen la misma
magnitud
entonces tengo mi cantidad de escalar
aceleración centrípeta como les digo no
es vector va a ser igual a la magnitud
del vector aceleración centrípeta uno
bueno lo pongo como los dibuje aquí
a uno a la magnitud de este vector que
es igual a la magnitud de la aceleración
2 que es igual a la magnitud del vector
aceleración 3
ahora lo que quiero pensar es que tanto
me lleva o me llevará para llegar desde
este punto hasta este otro punto este
recorrido de esta pues esta ruta
circular
entonces bueno tengo una forma de
resolverlo cuál es la longitud del arco
que se recorre en esta parte que es un
cuarto de circunferencia
más o menos es un cuarto de la
circunferencia
bueno
esta parte de esa circunferencia es
igual a 2
esta es la circunferencia total del
círculo por el radio r
multiplicado por 14
entonces también quiero saber bueno esta
es la longitud de este arco longitud del
arco
quiero saber también qué tiempo va a
tardar en recorrer este este cuarto de
circunferencia y para saber el tiempo
pues tengo que dividir la longitud del
recorrido entre la rapidez o lo que es
lo mismo no voy a escribir por acá el
tiempo que es un escalar que me lleva a
recorrer esto va a ser igual a la
longitud del arco que ya puse aquí que
es 2 pi por el radio aunque es r
multiplicado por un cuarto porque es una
cuarta parte de la circunferencia entre
la rapidez y la rapidez es ver
recordamos esto no es velocidad es
rapidez es una escala repites
y bueno aquí ya tengo el tiempo de
recorrido
y el tiempo que se tarda en recorrer
esta ruta pues va a ser exactamente el
mismo que voy a tomar para recorrer esta
parte de la circunferencia de este otro
círculo el de vectores de velocidad
bueno ahora el tiempo va a ser el mismo
pero ahora aquí la longitud va sea
diferente cuál es la longitud de esta
otra ruta pues igual tiene que ser un
cuarto de la circunferencia pero ahora
con este radio velocidad
entonces tengo que en este lado mi
tiempo de recorrido va a ser igual a la
longitud que es 2 pi
ahora el radio es la velocidad por un
cuarto porque son cuartos de la
circunferencia entonces ahora es un
cuarto de dos y ahora no es r es b
la rapidez
/ rey la
magnitud de la aceleración
qué es bueno digamos que la la velocidad
bueno la rapidez pero en este caso es
exactamente el correspondiente aquí
tenemos nuestros vectores velocidad que
es sobre lo que dividimos el tiempo y
aquí tenemos los tres vectores de
aceleración que sobre lo que vamos a
dividir aquí la longitud para obtener el
tiempo entre mis vectores bueno más bien
entre la magnitud de mi aceleración
centrípeta
estas dos cantidades son iguales este
tiempo va a ser el mismo entonces puedo
igualar ambos elementos de la ecuación
de manera que me queda 2 p
por radio o este radio
por un cuarto
entre la rapidez va a ser igual a igual
2 pink en este caso es el vector
velocidad por un cuarto
/ la aceleración
céntrica puedo simplificar estos
términos puedo quitar estos elementos de
aquí y que me quede
el radio entre la aceleración es igual a
la
perdón radio entre la rapidez es igual a
la rapidez entre la aceleración siente
que está si yo quiero dejar solita la
aceleración científica
puedo pasarla multiplicando o
multiplicar ambos lados por este término
aceleración salto centrípeta
multiplicado por el radio entre la
rapidez es igual a la rapidez
sigo simplificando es voy a multiplicar
todo por la rapidez
entonces me va a quedar la aceleración
centrípeta por el radio igual a la
rapidez por la rapidez la rapidez el
cuadrado
finalmente la aceleración sentir pp es
igual a mi rapidez al cuadrado entre el
radio que está es la misma fórmula la
que queríamos llegar desde el principio